Guys, before we get into the Costco sample strategy too heavily, I want to remind you
that every single thing that we have done up to this point leads to this moment.
The reason that this process works is because we give results in advance.
We give people value and the goal is to give more value than they can pay for.
We want to give our free stuff, we want to make it better than their paid stuff.
There's no coincidence that that's what I'm doing in the free group.
I'm trying to give this as an example.
I'm trying to show you guys if you give free value that's better than most people's paid,
people will buy.
That's the reason you're here.
I don't want to overwhelm you.
I don't want to freak you out.
I don't want you to overthink it, but I do want you to remember everything leads here
and I've seen a few people in the past.
They've done everything right up to this point.
They've hooked the business owner and they think the deal is done.
They think it's over.
Guys, it is not over.
You do not skip this step.
You do not gloss over this step.
You do not do this step differently than I'm going to teach you.
There is a correct way to send these samples.
There is an incorrect way to send these samples and I've done all of them.
I've tried all of them.
Trust me.
I'm going to teach you the way and some of you guys are going to listen to this way and go,
oh man, that takes a couple of steps.
Yes, it does, but it's going to speed the deal up.
It's going to overcut.
I'm going to get into all that in a moment.
I just want to stress the importance that this step is so important and this isn't a
super long module, but I want you to do this exactly as I teach it because this is key
to everything.
First of all, what I want to talk about is what is the Costco sample strategy?
Why do we call it that?
Costco is what they call a big box retailer.
Basically, for those of you that don't know, it's like a huge grocery store,
but the difference is you go in, they sell huge quantities.
Instead of selling a candy bar, they sell packs of 30 candy bars.
Instead of selling cheese, they sell bricks of cheese.
Instead of selling laundry detergent, they sell cases of it.
You have to have a membership and all this stuff, but what they do is on Saturdays,
every single Saturday, you can go in and at the end caps in different places throughout the store,
they position these booths.
These booths have these different products that they're trying to sell.
It's juice, it's cheese, it's sausage, it's bread.
They stick somebody behind these booths and all they do is they cook this food or they
pour these drinks and they hand samples out.
These people don't have sales experience.
These people are typically seniors who are literally just trying to make enough money
to live.
They're not high energy, young salespeople.
These are just people just doing their job, handing out samples.
I don't even think they train them on sales experience at all.
I don't think they train them at all.
Okay, but Costco's figured out that if you have a product that is good,
if you have a juice that tastes amazing, all you got to do is get people to try it
and they will buy, okay?
And it is exactly what we're doing, right?
We know our product's amazing, but we got to get people to try it.
And we want to do it with no risk.
We don't want them to have to pay for it in advance.
We want them to try it without having any type of payment without any type of risk, okay?
So that is why we call it the Costco sample strategy.
We are going to give the samples, okay, without asking for anything in advance.
We're just going to give them results in advance.
And this does a couple of things that I want to go over really quick.
The number one thing that doing this does is it overcomes the objection of trust.
I'm telling you guys, after having done sales for almost 10 years now,
the number one objection that's going to kill deals is trust.
If someone can't trust you, they will not buy, period.
And I could say that 100 times and I probably wouldn't say it enough.
You can do everything correctly.
You can have the perfect product.
They can need it.
They can want it.
They can have the budget.
Everything can make sense, but if they don't trust you, they will not buy.
If there is any doubt in their mind that your service is going to work,
they will not buy, okay?
So by sending these results in advance,
it is the quickest, fastest way to overcome the objection of trust.
And a lot of people think that the way to overcome trust is having a fancy website,
you know, having these little blurbs of customer testimonials at the bottom,
having reviews.
Guess what, guys?
I have never had an agency website.
And I've worked with companies doing $500 million in a year, okay?
They own multiple companies under their umbrella
and they have never looked at my website.
And you know why?
It's because I overcome the objection of trust by giving them results in advance, okay?
Those of you that are in this program watching this,
notice we never had a landing page.
Notice there's no page that has the fancy this and the fancy that
and it's laid out and it's sponsored by this
and it's approved by this and a stamp of approval by that.
You guys know that this works because you have seen how good my free content is
and so it only makes sense that my paid stuff is that much better, okay?
So the number one thing that this does by sending the results in advance
and by doing the Costco sample strategy is it overcomes the objection of trust.
The second thing that it does is it demands,
actually it demands and commands attention, okay?
Because no one else is doing it.
Nobody else is doing it and especially the way that we do it, okay?
I had one of our students, we recently interviewed her
and she said something to the effect that she got talking to this business owner
and she said, hey, you know, we do leads, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And the business owner cut her off and said, yeah, everybody does leads now.
Home advisor does leads and this and she said, yeah,
but do they give you free results in advance before they ever ask for a dollar?
And the business owner just kind of stopped
and didn't really know what to say and said, well, no, okay?
Guys, you have to realize and I think sometimes we forget because we do it
and we do it so often, we are literally giving them liquid gold,
not liquid gold, digital gold, right?
We're giving them jobs that if you're in the right niches
can be worth and are worth thousands and thousands of dollars, okay?
So second thing it does, it commands and demands attention.
The third thing this does, it shows the business owner,
we're not messing around, we mean business, we're calling them
and we are giving them results in advance, we mean business,
we're here to do a deal, we're not here to mess around,
we're not here to play around, we are here to get it done.
And so those three things are what allows the deal to be sped up,
it's what allows us to overcome the trust
and it's what allows the business owner to know, hey, this guy, this girl, this lady,
they're messing around.
Last thing guys, we are going to be doing these Costco samples live, okay?
We are not gonna be doing a text message,
we're not gonna be doing an email,
we sure as hell aren't gonna forward the calls directly to them in the beginning,
we are going to be doing these live, okay?
And the reason why we do it live is because we,
I personally and many of our students have experiences in the past
where they hear of this concept, they're like, yeah, that makes sense.
You give people results up front and you go and close them.
What happens is if you do this incorrectly and you just send over the leads
or you just forward the leads,
you'll jump on the call, the Zoom call at the end
and you're jacked, you're like, dude, I've sent 20 leads to this guy,
20 leads to this lady, she's gonna be closed.
You get on and you find out they've gotten a hold of one,
they've gotten a hold of two
and they haven't even given estimates to those two yet
or they've scheduled estimates
but they haven't even gone out to the estimates.
And literally, it doesn't, like you sending the 20 leads did nothing, okay?
And so the reason that we do it live
is it allows us to control the entire process, okay?
It allows us to hand them a hot lead.
It allows us to hand it off so they don't say something wrong.
It allows us to show them exactly what they're getting, okay?
And so doing this live is such an important piece of this puzzle.
We're gonna get into that later
and if you can't do it live and if you have a job, that doesn't matter.
We have solutions around that
but I do wanna tell you, if at all possible, we want to do these live.
Doing this live is the equivalent of Costco.
This is something they don't do.
This is the one thing I think they could do even better
is imagine if Costco that gives these free samples,
imagine if they came and they said,
hey, you can have this sample, this cookie is free,
this drink is free, this cheese is free
but you need to stand right there and I need to watch you eat it.
And that'd be a little bit weird
but the truth is sometimes I remember and I still do this,
I'll go and I'll grab the sample and then I'll kind of smell it
or I'll look at it or I'll give it to my kid or I'll throw it away
and if I don't taste it, I'm never gonna buy it, okay?
So it's almost like a waste of the sample
but if Costco said, hey, you can have a sample,
in fact, I'll give you three of them
but I want you to try them.
I want you to eat them right here
so I can see that you taste it, that you can try it, okay?
Because if your product is good, it's gonna sell itself
but they have to try it.
And so the reason that we do it live
is it forces the business owner to try and to taste our samples
and what's crazy and what's cool is we actually know
they're already in the market for this, okay?
This is like somebody already being in the market for cheese
and somebody at Costco being like,
hey, I know you're looking to buy cheese, come try this one, okay?
They don't do that, they give every sample to everyone.
We're only giving our samples to people that are looking
and already paying for a product or service similar, okay?
So just before we jump into this,
I wanna stress the importance.
Do not skip this step.
This step is an absolute game changer.
Doing it correctly is a game changer.
Don't breeze through this, don't rush through this,
don't think that the deal is done, it is far from done.
Do this correctly and we will close deals
and we'll close them fast.